there is a choice of three starters
marinated sardines with spicy sauce
grill pepper salad with Merguez sausages
now lab week and a break at Elysium
speciality pastry filled with tuna
potato and a soft egg then deep-fried
crisps for two minutes the egg yolk is
runny and I want them to experience the
day whenever they have 115 away in that
egg yolk should sort of run all over the
tuna yeah really really good not too
spicy not too sweet with the starters
over Christmas 30 complex mains to cook
on his tiny stove there are 3 choices of
tagine
Cod with king prawns and seafood chicken
with olives and preserved lemons or lamb
in a spicy sauce handed down from his
grandmother although he's got a sous
chef and two others to help him just as
I thought perfectionist Chris wants to
do everything himself if he carries on
like this food will be delayed now why
don't you do the Christmas Julia Nick
what's good yeah but he's doing
everything
it's just in the plates can you dress
the place you've got the one working
their pens everywhere one two three of
you do nothing
yeah it is the chef he doesn't want to
say bombers to the Bombers oh okay honey
anyway compassion cook yeah through the
bars it's more spaced out here that was
in there you've got to take some of the
responsibility away from him
come on it's incredible I mean I thought
I was a control freak
Chris takes it to a completely different
level and he just cannot delegate you're
a control freak
well I'm not the controller think about
what you doing everything
Nowell Nowell I just want to open up and
talk oh [ __ ] me I'm sure you get your
own finger Bowl and do you need them to
get you a finger Bowl do you do ya
one finger Bowl plays for the fished a
gene this is getting ridiculous front of
house should be help in the kitchen not
hindering finger ball it's potentially
catastrophic because he's so used to
that one-man band
tops of two stations again yet the drums
the guitar the opening of the mouth and
he's just playing everything and
everyone's running around and crazy